Speaker 1: If we want to find some good
news in the data, it's that Democrats keep
gaining on Republicans in 2022 election
polling. The numbers are not yet a delight,
but they're increasingly looking. Okay. Let's
start with the house. Why start with the House?
Well, Democrats are not favored to keep control of
the House. Democrats currently control the House
of Representatives. It is likely that they will
lose the House of Representatives. But the numbers
have been improving for Democrats every single day
for months. Where do the numbers stand now? The
FiveThirtyEight forecast for the House says that
it's a 74% chance that Republicans take the House
and a 26% chance that Democrats keep the House.
But look at the way the numbers have shifted.
If you scroll down on this FiveThirtyEight
page, which is very, very detailed and it's
a great forecast, you will see a section
called How the House Forecast has Changed.
And you will see that in early June, Democrats
had a 14% chance of holding the House. That even
dropped to 12 in late June, early July. But it has
been a steady but modest surge, almost doubling
the odds of Democrats keeping the House going from
actually more than doubling, going from a bottom
out of 12 to a 26% chance. Now, remember, things
that are 12% likely to happen sometimes happen,
things that are 26% likely to happen, sometimes
happen, but things that are 74% likely to happen
are more likely to happen by definition. So I
can't tell you that I think it's a great shot
for Democrats in the House, but the numbers have
been improving. And if Democrats keep adding on,
you know, a one percentage point chance
every other day between now and November,
that's 30. Right. That would put this at 5050 by
Election Day. So that's what's happening in the
House. Now, in the Senate, things are looking
much better for Democrats. In the Senate,
Democrats are now 70%, 70% likely to hold control
of the Senate, whereas Republicans are only 30%
likely. This has gone. Last week I told you it was
2 to 1 in favor of Democrats. It is now two and
a third or whatever. It's well beyond 2 to 1 at
this point in time. And again, these are numbers
that have improved for Democrats. There was a
point in early June where Democrats had a 40%
shot of holding the Senate. That is now a 70%
shot. Very, very important to understand, because
there are people writing to me saying, David, why
do you keep saying Democrats are going to have 70
senators? And of course, David is not saying that.
What I am telling you is that it is a 70% chance
that Democrats hold the Senate. The most
likely outcome is that Democrats hold it
51 to 49. That would be a gain of one seat. Right
now in the Senate, it's 5050. The vice president
gets a tie breaking vote. That's Kamala
Harris. So Democrats are in the majority,
5050 plus. Kamala, the most likely outcome
here is a 51 to 49 majority for Democrats. So
please do not write to me saying, David, Democrats
have no chance in hell of getting 70 seats. I'm
agreeing with you. That's not what the number
means. That's not what the number means. But I
appreciate everybody writing in. So the bottom
line, Democrats chances continuing to improve.
And if they merely continue improving
at the same rate, the House will end up
a 5050 flip of the coin by early November.
We will watch and see whether that happens.